foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up I'm Kim BHD here so a lot
happened during 2021 and also a lot
didn't happen
huh let's rewind and recap so in 2021 on
the MKBHD Channel we ended up making 93
Total videos all about tech tech
products Tech explainers talks with
creators and people in the tech world
this is the 93rd video that we're
watching right here which is technically
less than my goal of 100 videos roughly
during the course of the year and way
less than my 121 last year so it'd be
easy to get down on that but this year
we also started three other channels so
my podcast the waveform podcast is now
in video form we built up a video studio
for it and new episodes have continued
to drop every single week on Fridays
that's why we really get into the weeds
and the details on Tech stuff that's a
whole Channel there's also a waveform
Clips Channel started up this year I'll
link both of these below that like
button I'm gonna guess because I don't
know but that you shoot them with an
iPhone is that right and we also started
up the studio Channel which is a peek
behind the curtain you out into how the
team works here at the studio how we
cover the tech world and how we make all
these videos like how we turn a Thousand
Mile two-day road trip experiment into
an informative structured piece about
gas versus electric cars we've got
members we've got the whole team most of
the team here we're going to be in these
cars probably trash talking a little bit
and turning into a bit of a race but to
see exactly how much time charging at
these different infrastructures adds to
a road trip so when you include all
those the total goes from 93 to 93 plus
34 plus 96 plus 17 to equal
240 videos this calendar year which is
amazing and I'm very proud of all of
them and the work that we put into them
and really moving forward the saying
that's still always in the back of my
head every time I'm making something
like this is more better
more better really anytime you try to
make more of something typically the
quality goes down and anytime you spend
a lot of effort into making something
better typically you make less of them
and so our goal with the whole team at
the MKBHD studio is to make both more
and better and that's for you so now
here's five really large movements I
observed in the tech world this year so
number five short form content
is here to stay it's hooked it's caught
on and it feels pretty permanent and you
know for a while we've known short form
content is is getting popular the
explosion of tick tock over the past two
years but now Instagram adding reels and
YouTube really leaning into shorts
building it onto the website it's it
feels much more here to stay we always
knew there was something to it it's
arrived so I've experimented with shorts
a little bit and I've I've done we even
did one or two on the studio Channel I
wouldn't be surprised if we ended up
making an entire dedicated shorts
Channel just to play with this short
format because I do have a lot of fun
with them but I just want to make I
don't just want to make it because it's
popular I want to make good ones so
anyway stay tuned for that we'll
probably play with that a lot in the
next year or so in 2022 but yeah short
stuff
it's here then number four nfts
crypto web 3.0 Dogecoin it's funny I
don't talk about you know Finance stuff
necessarily that much on this channel
even though obviously it's a big part of
the tech world this this whole crypto
boom but you know there's a little bit
of a peek of it here and there I did
make a video about Dogecoin the rise and
fall of it what exactly it is what a
meme coin is but also we've been talking
about Bitcoin on the podcast people sold
an nft for 69 million dollars and then
he hopped on the waveform podcast and we
talked about it and about being a
Creator and how digital art is being
taken to the next level with this sort
of stuff so I'll leave a link below if
you want to watch that one but yeah let
me know if you'd be interested in more
crypto coverage or crypto videos or
anything sort of like that in 2022. so
the number three custom silicon
underrated really I really feel like
this is underrated for how much this is
changing the landscape of tech and how
much it will continue to do so going
forward so we already knew the a series
of chips in iPhones were custom designed
by Apple but then they brought the M1
chip in this apple silicon takeover of
their whole lineup into MacBook Air
MacBook Pro Mac Mini and even iPad Pro
and they did really great then we saw
the next level Step Up of M1 Pro and M1
Max chips in the MacBook Pros and those
had huge huge performance and efficiency
gains over the Intel versions Google's
tensor chip in the pixel had a bunch of
advantages over the previous chips off
the shelf that allowed them to make
pixel 6 one of the best actually the
best value phone of the year thanks to
the smartphone Awards and this is
something I fully expect to continue
much more into next year more phone
manufacturers even tablet and laptop and
headphone and other company
manufacturers doing more with
proprietary silicon that they design
in-house so if I was is Qualcomm or
Intel right now I'd be paying very close
attention to this then number two
alternate form factors they gain just a
little bit of momentum and a little bit
more usability every single year really
it started back to when we got Samsung Z
flip 3 which gave you basically all the
normal experiences of a flagship phone
that could fold in half and actually
launched at basically the same price as
a lot of other Flagship phones 9.99
which is right inside a lot of other
flagships but we've since then of course
seen many others we have the larger fold
three we have the midsize Oppo Find n
the Razer gave us something different
there's also the xiaomi Mi mix fold
there's also Huawei mate X2 surface Duo
2. there's just a bunch of different
experimentation playing with the form
factor but it's all getting more usable
and slowly coming down in price it's not
immediately here but it's clearly
working its way towards being arrived so
there will be more and I'm sure they'll
all be better in 2022 but that leaves us
at number one which is ev's electric
vehicles and specifically a lot of those
trucks I've said this before but every
year for the next decade is going to be
the most interesting year yet for
electric cars now for the past two or
three years or so we've been getting a
lot of promises you know this company
promises they'll have 20 EVS by 2030 and
this other company promises to Electrify
their whole lineup in the next eight to
12 years great great that's all great
the promises are great but now it's time
to start shipping them so in 2021 we got
the headliners we got rivien r1t we got
the Hummer EV we got Ford F-150
Lightning announced at least we got
Lucid air we got Tesla Model S plaid
that's all already enough to get a lot
of people interested but they're also
pretty premium so you also get things
like the Volkswagen id4 the Nissan Leaf
the Mini Cooper S A lot of the lower
priced EVS that will actually move
volume and I think it's pretty easy to
say they will be way more next year and
it's going to be fascinating to see how
they all differentiate themselves what
features they'll offer how their Tech
gets better how many miles they'll be
able to offer at certain price ranges
it's going to be good I fully plan to
check out as many as I possibly can and
hopefully bring you guys videos of those
and I'll continue to write articles for
Top Gear while I'm at it now okay in the
spirit of rewinding not everything was
amazing and perfectly exactly how we
expected in 2021 so here's the top five
things that didn't come out during 2021
that maybe we were hoping for or that we
expected to so number five the Samsung
Galaxy Note
this is interesting we didn't get a new
note this entire year the last Galaxy
Note was the Galaxy Note 20 and that
wasn't a great phone but we had an
entire gap for 2021 where there was no
phone with an S Pen built in there were
phones that supported the S Pen and that
was an interesting Clause the S Pen is
not dead but now I wonder if we're going
to ever see another note again if
they're just saving it for early next
year we'll have to see now number four a
foldable pixel and or a pixel watch we
got pixel 6 and pixel 6 Pro and they
were both really interesting phones in a
lot of ways the tensor chip the new set
of cameras the new hardware design the
new material you software all of that
very interesting to watch
um but no pun intended there was no
watch and you know we were hoping to see
maybe like an Apple Watch equivalent for
Android Straight from Google and that
seems to be rumored heavily but we
haven't seen it yet I honestly think
it could be a couple years out and same
thing with a foldable pixel we have all
this software support from Google for
foldables now but we don't have a sort
of standard Google foldable I also don't
think we're going to be seeing that
anytime soon the rumors keep churning in
the background which is kind of
interesting but yeah that's a little
ways out then number three Tesla's stuff
cyber truck being one and then plaid
plus and Roadster being others so really
the Cyber truck was one that we're I
guess maybe starting to hope we might
see on the road this year but it is
delayed chip shortage a lot of things
got delayed this year this is one of the
casualties and now it's officially well
hopefully coming at the end of 2022 but
also Tesla announced the Plaid Model S
and the Plaid plus Model S the Plaid
plus ended up getting completely
canceled because it was unnecessary and
they ended up just shifting all of that
into Tesla Model S plaid production a
very strange turn of events I haven't
seen a car announced and canceled like
that before even after they took orders
for it but that was sort of a blip on
the Tesla radar and uh
our Roadster friend is uh still not out
I don't know I didn't think it would be
out by now I was kind of hoping back in
2017 when they announced it that it
would be out by 2021 even though it was
a 2020 announced car yeah it's later
it's like 2023 or 24 now so number two
an apple silicon true desktop and I said
true desktop meaning the Apple silicon
iMac Pro
or apple silicon Mac Pro so we have the
Apple silicon M1 iMac which had a lot of
really nice things to it it's a thin
all-in-one for a sort of everyday crowd
not too performance focused but
obviously very capable now we're looking
forward to seeing what they can really
unleash with a bigger chip in a desktop
and for me iMac Pro seems like it'll be
really cool probably high refresh rate
high resolution nice black bezel maybe
but then Apple silicon desktop like the
Mac Pro
that's the one I really should be
waiting for and then number one
any sub 30 000 EV well almost I'll say
any good one I mean we had okay the
Nissan Leaf came out it had like a 29
000 starting price and I think it had
about 150 miles of range something like
that but what I'm really looking forward
to is when we start getting the premium
EV experience lower and lower in price
whether that's the Tesla Model 2 that's
rumored or maybe that's some other
company that's beating them to the punch
but I would love to see a sub thirty
thousand dollar accessible
Evie with let's go 220 miles of range or
more to really make it more than just a
quick little commuter vehicle that would
be awesome to see it didn't come out
last year didn't come out in 2021 I
think we might see it in 2022 but anyway
that's it for my rewind for 2021 Tech
I'm gonna wrap it up on a positive note
by giving you down below five Great Tech
videos that came out this year that
weren't published by me that I still
think you really should watch so just
open the description down below the like
button and check out all the stuff down
there but either way that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace